[Music]
welcome
to comic con
the signature pop culture event of the
southwest
before we begin i regretfully have to
announce a few last
minute
tragedies smush was smashed
o'neil shaquille blew out his heel
and may never dance again
britney shears will not be giving
sloan-quality haircuts as she's gone
into a conair savored your ship
conair is a brand of hair dryers
under her father
reverse strippers were all indicted on
tax fraud
and finally
we aren't legally zoned for horse
funerals so instead i'll be out back
burning horse carcasses for the next
hour or so at the conclusion so now
without further ado
let's
start the show all right
wow
welcome to the break room
uh this is the new rockstar's live nerdy
news show coming to you every weekday at
3 p.m pacific as we are now directly
from the new rockstars offices but this
is no normal episode of the break room
as you can already tell
from that um completely indecipherable
i mean that was a deep cut you've got to
be following the comic-con more i
appreciate that more more complicated
lore than uh doctor who yeah at the top
of comic con um
but uh uh so this is tomicon uh as tommy
said the biggest
signature event of the southwest pop
culture we've been teasing it for weeks
you the viewers have both donated to it
and demanded it frankly yeah we've got
an insane amount of games special guest
prizes events segments it's wild but
first
we're gonna do the normal break room
stuff yeah okay we're gonna deliver
we're gonna deliver on the promise of
the title and thumbnail of this video uh
with me to do that i've got my good
friend mr brandon barrick i love that
in in some wonderful homemade cosplay
there oh well i paid big bucks for them
okay well still homemade but paid big
money it's a good homemade uh jessica
clemens is here hi
also cosplaying yes i feel like a lot of
you guys in the chat don't know what i
am and it's okay
i'm punchline joker's girlfriend in the
new series
she's amazing and i love her to death
yes they knew and if they didn't know
what are you doing really if you don't
know read a book now you do know now you
know uh and then not not currently
cosplaying but that could change tom
spectal
i'm cosplaying as a dirty little stinker
okay that's
that's most days uh and then i'm zach
holliston and i'm thrilled to be here
with you um
i'm cosplaying as
your dad's friend yeah yeah
that's right
i watch a lot of videos on pornhub about
dad's friends oh my gosh
all right let's do that
thanks family for watching by the way
thanks for all the extra family members
tuning in oh uh real quick sorry we're
not moving onto the deadlines quite yet
we do have some really fun redemptions
today thank you to everybody that's
already throwing in super chat
[Music]
karaoke i'm not going to explain that
any further i feel like it's pretty um
pretty self-explanatory yeah or we do
have a uh a mystery box
uh as well yeah um both of those things
will be unlocked at intervals of a
hundred dollars we appreciate everybody
who's chatting super chatting all of the
above and i have to mention the buckets
are filled with artifacts from the tom
bechtold archives yes yes rare treasures
from my home
and other places that i have stumbled
across
we're all the multiverse we were lucky
to get them online uh also we have some
great some comic-con exclusives we're
doing march drops today you don't have
to give us a penny to get those in fact
john if you could throw up the email
address
if you just want to email us your
contact info email us your name and your
mailing address and we're sending out
tomicon posters crafted here by the
break room art department uh those are
exclusives there and then this is tommy
bechdel's first ever headshot
look how young and innocent you look we
will sign these and send them to you you
go ahead and hang on to that we'll make
tommy sign those yes if you want someone
else to sign tommy's head shot just drop
that in there yeah so email us and we'll
be picking random people and send it
along
uh treasures for all yes
uh now headlines okay
yeah they're playing that graphic okay
great uh ben affleck's batman confirmed
to return in aquaman two yeah what a
unique turn of events that is when i
picture batman i picture undersea
adventures yes we got um i think we have
a pic posted by jason momoa can we throw
that up there
we do not have a pic well i can let's
recreate it
oh
ben i think he's not smiling i'll tell
you something
okay then i'm a moa sad flick there you
go
but yeah uh ben affleck's batman
appearing like a strange like
continuation of the snyder version and i
knew this i knew this a month ago
i got an email a month ago from a
casting site asking for extras for
aquaman 2 and one of the requests
was a stand-in for ben affleck and you
know what i did i zipped my little lips
and i didn't tell anyone because i
didn't want our daddies at warner
brothers and discovery to be mad at us
so i shut up about it and now it's
scooped it could have been me i could
have been a scooper i could have been
the new woes
bombing for you
fans nikki fink for those yeah did you
submit it
a week after at the the warner brothers
panel at comic con when they dropped
that new shazam trailer
you see ben affleck's batman in that
trailer right when he talks about like
kind of members of the justice league
right uh interesting um
we also got some new shield footage
uh that dropped uh in the last 24 hours
revealed that um uh a shang chi shang
chi post scene connection
um we all said that post-criticism bruce
is in a sling right in his human mark
ruffalo form
right in this footage brandon do you
want to describe it real quick yeah it's
like it shows him wearing this sling in
a similar manner so we're wondering if
this is like the moment but this also is
before the car crash i believe
uh that we see him in the slang or
around like i don't know when you say
the car crash the car crash we know is
the kind of the origin point for
jennifer walters becoming she we heard
her say that like she got exposed to
hulk's blood uh and we're we're now
thinking like this car crash is that
scenario where it happens like in the
comics she's given the blood to like
save her life in a transfusion but this
might happen accidentally i guess which
is also interesting because hulk's blood
has accidentally gotten on to other
people uh in previous films
or even into bottles of cola even into
stan lee it got it um which it's also
interesting one thing we don't know is
the timeline because in the trailer for
she-hulk all that we see of both mark
ruffalo and the hulk no arm sling right
yeah yeah so some at some point maybe do
you think the car crash like fixed his
arm you know like how if you get if you
get one concussion it messes you up
oh yeah that's what that's like three
and a half and nobody knows always
always end on odds they say always end
up
so there's still some answers to be
determined there about that um uh okay
oh we got kevin feige said that there's
more announcements that haven't been
announced yet
um we have we've been assuming as much
obviously the the phase six yes lineup
is still pretty empty and even there are
some spots open in the phase five lineup
that we've been making some assumptions
about we don't know and then obviously
casting and director news things like
that there's a lot of those to be filled
in i think he's just holding out for d23
yeah and that's why he's like clearly
there's a lot of stuff that we're going
to talk about that's right right which
is crazy because they said so much in
common we were kind of surprised at
everything they got revealed if they're
going to drop out even more at d23
that'll be really
interesting coming in september we'll be
covering it probably live on the break
room you better believe um cool and we
are eagerly anticipating what's your
best
name one thing that you think will get
dropped it
the mutants yeah i think though i think
saying like what the mutant movie is
gonna be for sure yeah that would be
crazy i am just really hoping that we
get uh we get a midnight sun's just a
little like a
promise of it do you think series or
film
i wouldn't mind if it was a film i mean
the series sounds great but i mean just
to get give it the star power and full
gravity make it a film make it a film
maybe if it could go to theaters too
might get a little yeah they can maybe
make it a little darker midnight showing
for midnight sun
um
it's too late we gotta get our rest um
in a disney plus series news olivia
coleman is rumored to be playing union
jack
in secret invasion
uh kind of a gender swap uh for the how
that character is typically portrayed in
comics but interesting we know she's
been cast of course olivia coleman from
um the favorite oscar winner
lost daughter which was a real heavy but
wonderful netflix film this year um
uh tears in the chat for lost daughter
okay
and then
finally we've got an interesting quote
from taran edgarton
um
saying that he turned down the role of
han solo presumably this was in the
i don't think it was that one yeah yeah
uh
but he kind of gave this one quote um
uh i you know basically saying like when
i read kingsman i knew this was a great
thing yeah and suddenly throwing some
shade yeah a solo script i think well i
think also i mean to be fair kingsman is
like his movie where yeah
with a lot of pressure
solo would have been everyone's movie
he's like i'm the lead and i'm the only
person you care about in this movie yes
uh yeah that's a great point also though
karen ederson i'm watching the apple uh
plus series uh blackbird right now he's
in it he does a good job and he's gotten
particularly jacked yeah i'm just
throwing that out there dude seems
suspicious
for a specific role that's suspicious
with my boy paul walter hauser come on
he has not gotten jacked yeah he will
but he will don't worry
paul you are beautiful just the way you
are my baby boy now
somebody call him a jewel yeah richard
baby beat me out for that real quick
okay
before you transition your tummy i just
want to say throw in the chat we're
going to be doing a lot of tamacon q a's
yeah uh so if you have like a tamicon
based question yeah throw that in there
we'll be trying to collect those and
we'll get to as many of those as well
now
what type of man
requests that his friends throw a comic
book convention named after him with
graphics in his honor
themed games and trivia questions all
about him the type of man that could use
a little better help so we want to thank
our friends at better out for sponsoring
the break room this week multiple folks
in the nr staff have used better help in
the past and i'm currently using it
obviously we're big fans of taking care
of your mental well-being we're on team
mental health guys the other team not so
good a few folks at the channel whoa boy
okay sorry a few folks the channel have
even helped set up better help accounts
for their family members that have never
tried online therapy before or need a
little encouragement so you got a cranky
uncle that's feeling a little down in
the dumps sign him up online i'm telling
you it's very easy i did it myself you
should see me on a computer it's the
monkey with a typewriter thing like
eventually
i'm going to write hamlet but for now
i'm just writing
here
exclamation point colon anyway better
help online therapy will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist in less
than 48 hours took 24 hours for me and i
already have an appointment set up it's
a more affordable way than traditional
online therapy financial aid is
available check out all the testimonials
they have on their website if you don't
believe me big t okay these are real
users sharing their experience with
better health therapists and here is the
really cool part in honor of all week
and tomicon i feel they are offering us
a special offer for our breakers our
roomies your trash bags get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
breakroom so use that code breakroom
that's ten percent off your first month
of online therapy at betterhelp.com
break room love you guys thank you
better health for helping us uh bring
both comic-con and all of our episodes
this week
folks um now
that concludes the sane portion of
today's it's time
to rip the band-aid we're going to
quickly uh tear down the set and
assemble the set for tomicon and i think
there's a video yeah we actually have a
slideshow of all of you amazing break
room uh viewers and fans that sent in
your cosplay we're gonna play some of
those cosplay right now while we turn
the set over
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
all right
[Music]
oh cosplays
those asking if this is cosplay
everything is cosplay at tomicon because
you could always be impersonating me at
my fluctuating weights throughout my
adult life
any body types of body type when it's a
tommy body type now
we crossed over 100 so we're halfway to
200 so we're going to do a song from the
karaoke roulette and we're all going to
sing to get us started everybody's going
to join in and let's see what song we
got first kicking us off all
it's a beautiful song from disney's the
lion king
whoa
starting us off in ball pit karaoke
anna's here
it's comic-con
um i'm so excited to be here sorry i'm a
little late i heard there were karaoke
shots in the ball pit
ball
all right
come on in yeah
[Music]
early
[Music]
i'm gonna be a mighty king so enemies
beware
i've never seen a kibble beach with
quite so little hair oh i'm gonna be the
main event like no king was before yes
i'm brushing it up i'm looking down i'm
working on my
before a very uninspiring
[Music]
no one's saying stop that don't think
that no one's saying see
here around all day like a bunch of
friends
wow
merciful ending any anymore we have to
pay royalties that was great that was
great thank you anna and tommy before i
head out i brought one more thing to
offer up
uh last time i was on the show which was
18 years ago the true ones i we did a
little morbius uh a mad lib whoa
oh that's a real merch on the back
a little tiny morbius you get that dash
i can't even tell it's too light wait oh
there we go there we go angle it away
that's the trick uh to the the person
who donates the most oh we're gonna get
some signatures
[Applause]
you're gonna have to keep track of that
i love y'all
there's a snack table with like cheese
covered yeah
those are my grapes trades hands off my
traipse thank you thank you
anna the push yeah
heading back to sherwood forest there
is that 1000 acre woods
now
all right that felt good i want to thank
some of our super chatters already that
have been yeah we got gregor saying uh
old gregor rather saying empty in my
pockets for tommy khan yes
capilana an appreciation of the
fantastic president loki costume lots of
compliments for president yes
nimbus galleon go bills zach wearing his
lost sdcc coverage suit yeah good call
back there nimbus yes uh also a shout
out to our our good uh friend justin
allen yes uh can we get an answer to
what song is playing in the break room
please i think that's a frequently
speculated about thing about what our
what our intro song is purple fire
purple
people are asking the headshots and
prints are free you just have to email
the email address that we had with your
uh with your address to send it to and
we're going to randomly pick i mean or
if nobody emails we'll just send it to
everyone who does the only one so i'm
saying right now based on the uh amount
of interest you're gonna get one uh
now
we are honored and contractually
contractually obligated to have our dear
friend brandon barrick present this next
comic con moment please give it up for
brandon
thank you thank you
thank you hi baby uh i if i make it
serious for me i know real quick can you
just intro this why are you about to do
this you've earned the right
i won one of the mandatory funds from a
previous week uh and i earned this right
to have time here at tomicon okay and
i'm gonna use it all right we all love
the heroes of the mcu they're great but
you know what you can't have a hero
unless you have a villain all right and
the villains matter and you know what
happens to villains in the mcu they get
killed and it's not fair and we never
take a moment to appreciate their grace
their greatness so i'm gonna use my
soapbox moment to memorialize some of my
favorite dead villains of the mcu uh if
we get started off with our first one
here
uh it filled my heart with so much pain
to see the death of obadiah stain he
crossed the line and didn't look back
because tony stark built this in a cave
with a box of scraps
birthdate unknown death 2009. we're
going in chronological order on these no
no these are just in whatever order but
he started us off okay
oh my god i'm sorry another villain that
we did see fall was the big ass nose of
ebony maw you had the magic and strange
couldn't fight it but maybe someday
we'll be
re-united birthday unknown death date
2018.
sing a song
on a thousand pianos for the death of my
big purple boy thanos
you were a villain that wasn't so nice
and that my friend is why you had to die
twice thanos 10 13 to 2018 slash 2023 10
13. yeah he was born a long time ago
he's an old man he's a man
uh now let's talk about quite a great
loss
the disappearance of my boy
darren cross
maybe he's dead wrong photo maybe he's
not
but let's get this egomaniac back in the
plot bring him back just send him to the
quantum realm and bring it back someday
i i don't know i don't know oh aldrich
killian
i want to see you kill again
you were a villain with no true
successor of your death well the
reasoning is there simply was too much
seasoning you could handle the salt but
not the pepper he was killed by pepper
potts someone put her on trial please
the man was killed the man was killed
oh here's a tough one here's a here's a
real tough one oh wait aldrich killian
birthday unknown 2012 is when he died
twin tweets
here's a tough one
oh
malekith
actually who cares about malcolm
birthday unknown death date 2013. uh and
if i may one one last one to take us out
uh let's talk about a great man done in
by a bunch of losers
my boy ronan the accuser
his face was blue his eye shadow did run
and when it came to cleansing the galaxy
he had tons of fun oh
guys let's not forget our villains all
right thank you bless you all
[Music]
[Applause]
brandon speak at my funeral speak at my
wedding oh i'll be at your funeral
jessica dancing on your grave
i take it back i don't want you there
wow thank you brandon barrack unless
it's a two-step thank you uh well oh i
think we've got a special a special
guest who
ready to approach here uh
i mean honestly
hearing from folks this was the most
anticipated panel at this year's comic
con we're very excited to have our next
guest uh he just flew in from turks and
caicos uh
please give it up for hollywood mega
producer and man about town t michael
bechtol
i haven't seen this many loose balls
flopping around all right since i hosted
hanson at the chateau marmont 2011. oh
gosh oh they're already in their 30s
yeah they were well above age if you
notice the date don't fact-check me
oh what a great time for team michael
beck told in the team michael bechtel
studios my son and personal raven
perseus has come across the board and is
now reacting as executive vice president
slash pr person for the firm perseus
what do you think about our next phase
or as we call it
fade five awesome oh perseus
don't gass me up before we show the
trailers that's right we brought teasers
oh this first trailer is a labor of love
and a passion project we've been excited
to send your way for years
without further ado
let's take a look at the first part of
the team michael bechdel cinematic
universe with this teaser well
this guy's a total has been all right
he's a mess he's ever going to be here
on time i can't i can't bring my wife
around that's for sure i can't leave my
stuff sitting around the office
absolutely not no way
that guy i already lives on his kid's
couch
i thought he died years ago
one word
total loser
he's gonna ruin the credibility of the
show
he'll host the break room
yeah
yeah i'll do it
do me a favor
introduce me as fart simpson
wow wow
wow
early previews of this film have
garnered such reactions as no
uh we do have time to take a few
questions from our panel yes uh
yeah um the whole crew on set said that
you smelled like wet hay the whole time
can you explain why yeah wet hay diet my
doctor dr nasty uh had prescribed me a
diet it's basically 16 servings of wet
hay a day
uh and then you do one uh you excrete
via your sweat glands so you don't go
one or two you go six now just a quick
question is wet hey that's not the same
as grass no no one grass are completely
yeah hey hey it's for horses and grass
is for ass okay you know what i'm saying
thank you mr bechtel great question hey
get that girl's number for me will you
absolutely
first time long time my name is miles
morales hey listen uh mr t michael
bechtel yes uh is perseus there is he a
crow or a raven or just an extension
perseus is uh first of all a gift from
god oh yeah second of all my very best
friend and third of all very private
about what type of bird he is and it's
frankly none of your business get out of
here
mr t michael yes oh yeah oh i'm i'm
trying to grow my beard like you yeah
it's not it's not very good i was
wondering what is your grooming regimen
ah yes well uh i go to this club called
burley's
and i rub my beard against the other
burly bears and it's just a kind of a
symbiotic relationship i get their beard
seeds on me they get my beard seeds on
them at the end of the day i don't know
if it works but it feels good it's a
great way to spend 11 and a half hours
on a sunday i think they might have
tricked you t michael i don't think
that's bert beard seed oh okay oh oh no
all the way i'm going fine get him out
of here
thank you billy budget
all right love your work on the amazon
prime now
before we leave i've got one more
surprise oh oh another surprise i've got
another teaser trailer for what
the end of fade five if all goes well
this film will be released on the day of
my sentences oh okay
go ahead
this is kicking off fake six or as i
call it the penal code oh okay
go ahead and play the footage
look
i know you're my twin brother and we
haven't seen each other in 13 years but
it doesn't have to go this way
i'm just a lawyer a lawyer with all
human organs all organs that are human
parts
not animal parts
you're
or alive
but
how is this possible
say goodbye tommy
oh
really but the t-rex are inside you huh
tell my wives
i love them
all we have left are snake hearts
mess with the wrong guy we put a giraffe
liver a hippo kidney and a crot and
crocodile hips in the sky
he survived
all that
send in the asset
see if we can handle that
the last thing you counted on
was a lawyer with a skunk heart
case dis woofed
wow
that was like wow that was like tree of
life
yeah it was like a it was like an art
film i like how you play with the aspect
ratios that's my favorite part you put
your heart and soul into something that
you see your baby birth live on screen
wow there's so much blood there's so
much mucus in the papoosa or whatever
it's called what is that baby birthed
life in the movie that was the extended
beck told t michael bechtel's uh family
on display there i just want to thank i
found all those orphans and i adopted
them and i immediately sent him back but
they were great on film and they were
great sports thank you all
i've had a great time here at domicon i
gotta go
stick around
i'm having drinks with chevy chase on
jeffy chase boulevard in glendale but
he's problematic that's right we're
gonna have a head butting contest and a
butt heading contest oh that was great
wow
thank you team michael bechtold from t
michael bechtold studios that child was
a good actor that's all that wasn't
anything i could say also i just want to
say you know you've heard of kevin feige
that was um kevin fakey okay
uh you gotta quit quit backing out of
your own jokes you guys you guys give
some applause to zach here in the chat
wow it's always a pleasure to have t
michael here and that was definitely the
most epic t-michael appearance uh real
quick i want to shout out um hey and
thank you everybody throwing throwing
doubloons in the super chat there oh
we've got to open up one of the mystery
boxes now we've got uh three numbered
mystery boxes down here none of us have
any idea what's in them yeah jessica do
you want to uh
can i choose
pick one hey guys what'd i miss oh yeah
you missed the t-michael panel oh right
the whole fade five was announced yeah i
love that guy the fade five yeah
i'm gonna punch number two punch number
two for us okay we have no idea what's
in there a punch from punchline here we
go
spaghetti give her the spaghetti
it's a teddy roosevelt action figure yes
very tommy purchased live at the
virginia comic con run by my good friend
brett
you too can carreras
an action figure of one of our great
presidents who also led the great
massacres in the philippines
a lot of revisionist history with a
little teddy bear
technically the doll did nothing bad
well you know what we can pop another
one if you give generous that's right
that's right we're about 38 dollars away
from another uh
scorpions
the other two are snake based uh i won't
lie
uh real quick we want to debut a new
segment we're doing here on the break
room uh we're taking a brief hiatus a
bathroom break from temecon if you will
uh to debut fresh faced friday sponsored
by geology uh this is a new segment
we're gonna do um where we're going to
introduce the break room uh
audience to somebody who's kind of
making a big debut in a property we're
really excited about and just kind of
give them a little a little spotlight a
little love and of course today one of
the biggest properties coming up and a
new face showing up in that is tina
cuerta uh neymar yeah
we're very excited uh i think we've got
a very attractive uh image of him that
we can put up on screen john
stand by uh but um uh again he's gonna
be playing namor in uh black panther
wakanda forever that trailer of course
blew all of our brains out the back of
our skulls and melted down our backs um
and
i i personally have not seen any of his
other works um he's mostly most of his
filmography is spanish language he's
been working for like 15 years in mexico
and doing spanish language things uh but
english-speaking audiences might be most
familiar with him he was in the forever
purge
and uh narcos mexico
that's been off of the narcos franchise
and you know brandon one thing i saw in
his filmography spanish language that uh
interested me
he was in a series called uh blue demon
about the famous luchador blue demon
where he was portraying the blue demon
so we know he's capable of some physical
action stunt working kind of stuff okay
um and oh there
maybe we've got the image okay um but uh
you know whether you there he is look at
that handsome fresh face beautiful well
and you know what you know you got to
have if you're going to be cast as
marvel's most famous underwater hero
good lung capacity and moisturized skin
right and that's where our friends at
geology come in okay
uh yeah if if you want to have nice
refreshed uh ocean kissed
skin yes head over to geology
geology.com
new rockstars you can see that link here
in the description or on screen that you
could take a little test they'll send
you
they'll kind of prescribe all the great
different skincare products you need
your different creams and moisturizers
and washes and all that kind of stuff
and if you use our code or you go to
that link
use our code
rockstar 70. you can save 70 off a
30-day trial yeah they're giving it away
yes uh so thank you to geology for uh
helping us bring this show to you thank
you to tinacuerta for portraying neymar
in the uh the film where am i saying
namor right sure you say more or namor i
think you say it however you want to say
i put a heart and i think you say namor
okay thank you
i think the end is silent it's a more oh
hey that's that's a more egg yeah no a
moray eel okay uh all right now we're
transitioning back to full the promised
comic-con lineup
that's right there would be no tommy
without my sweet queen
my moon and stars my angel on earth
jessica clemens and there will be no
comic-con
without just fest so please
let me turn the keys over to the
cadillac
to my sweet sweet baby
welcome to jess fair
hi
hi hi hello welcome to jeff's fest i'm
more than ecstatic to get even a small
portion of tommycon and a little bit of
your time uh the heart of justfest is
actually in friendship friendship is key
and you know what else is key
testing your friends and seeing who
knows you the best oh
a series of short questions here for you
in the chat to also guest because watch
one of you in the chat actually be my
best friend
uh opposed to these fools you need that
markup oh yes and can we use tom and
eric as our photo friends
yeah get in here
all right everybody in everybody
yes yes there's no true tradition tom uh
tommy made tommy khan based off himself
jess fest is based off me and the only
egotistical way i can make it up more
about me is forcing you guys to answer
some questions
the chat is all positive jessica what if
someone said my lotion queen
yeah we're we're sure that's a
compliment yeah yeah oh i put on lotion
all the time i actually spent about a
month at the lotion king's house and let
me tell you
it was a pure nightmare
all right that's my dad
well look ask him to have some surfaces
you can sit on without sliding away
let's start this off goddamn water park
in there let's start this off right you
guys
what's my favorite word
what's jessica's favorite word what do i
love to say and say very often this word
i say maybe up to ten times a day okay
minimum
okay all right let me know when you guys
all have i got it
i went with tommy
i went with
gazebo
like in a yard yeah
what's wrong i don't i've never lived in
a house you're always like coming to the
gazebo
oh there you go oh okay
r2d2 scream yeah
what'd you write jess loves telling
people just no no no no no
i just put oh yeah
it's no surprise that one of you did get
it correct
jessica before we get to question two
unfortunately we do have to sing another
song
would you do the honors of pulling a
song for us here we go i'll go sit in
the basket with you if you want
all right someone someone else take the
lead on this one just get a task oh this
is my own worst enemy by lynn
here we go justin's favorite do you want
a different one pick another one pick
another one
my worst enemy nope already picking
another
jose rodriguez mr feeney
uh hey sing along with us queens don't
stop me now
tell me when to speak
darlene i saw that super chat darlene
thank you tell me
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dividing the laws of gravity
i'm a racing cause
i'm gonna go go go go stop
oh
[Applause]
we didn't think this through with the
balls coming out
of the ground oh if the bbs was there if
i had a dollar for every time i didn't
think about my balls coming out okay
don't eat the ball
okay second question
second question okay i'm ready second
question
who is my favorite dc character uh who
is my favorite dc character okay
okay
[Music]
okay
who is my favorite dc character
okay blue beetle blue beetle
okay okay i went
with dr gazebo oh yeah
we know who the exact opposite of this
is
go ahead uh shot in the dark okay i'm
gonna say icon oh okay
i love that song by will smith's son oh
great flashlight obviously oh my god oh
my god they're they're total guests
green lantern
okay
you you like you like a lot of man yeah
so i went with king shark
i see that jeremy mammon and the chat
got it it's harley quinn
looks like the chats more my friends
okay i got one other one for you what's
my favorite mcu movie
what's my favorite mcu movie oh okay
okay
this is friday or without time or uh
this is oh i got you i got you i got
that i get a half point if i get two
things half point yeah i'll give you a
half point everyone's not uh can i get
one 28 things you can guess one thing
yeah yeah yes
i got it this is easy
now
movie okay i'm going for the whole point
move
okay movie sammy i'm sorry you did i
just looked up and i saw the first one
you guys a lot of you said it a lot of
you guys don't apologize
it's pretty unanimous in the chat very
interesting well okay what did you say
well here tell me you want to start us
out as you've been starting black
panther
certainly your favorite recent trailer
okay well mine's it mine's a slow reveal
because of course there are i don't want
to look and there are a couple that have
this title of course it's captain
america
gazebo wow
go ahead all right hopefully i get some
good cool points for uh illustration
captain marvel oh oh god he got the logo
okay she's insulted
we all know it's guardians of the galaxy
uh this is the only one i've heard you
say on the show and it was thor ragnarok
okay
i said shang chi and the legends of the
ten
i will say brandon was close but not as
close as anna and the champ
all the time
another one another one but i need you
guys to all look at me look at me look
at me no one look away okay name at
least one toy on my desk oh okay name at
least one toy that's on my desk i have
13 toys on my desk being your office
mate i should get that yes you should
yes anna you should know this
no one like zach look at me don't look
over there don't look over there i'm not
i'm not looking i can't see that far
okay
um
okay i got it i got it i think i got
this one i got this one um
i'll go first oh you're good i said some
weird anime [ __ ]
i i also said anime statue big boobs
short skirt
i don't like where this is going i'm
going to skip zach for now oh what do
you got eric and you you too tom you too
billy
um i'm going to make a safe guess to say
grogu
oh yeah that's a good one okay what do
you got eric
two answers
okay baby groot and or ramen air
purifier
okay
okay i'm gonna say i know somebody has
this and i forgot who but uh batman
funko pop okay in a gazebo yes
okay i said a partially built little 3d
paper dude that we couldn't figure out
how to make yeah
anna who should be right but i threw
mine away halfway
i'm gonna give three points
one over here for the ramen air purifier
one here for weird animation and one
last one yes
this is the last one this is the last
one that all of you guys should guess
correctly did you take it off like that
john john brought it over i didn't touch
it it's john's fault i'm afraid to touch
that thing you guys
and people in the chat
what's my mom's name
what's my mom's name i say this all the
time i bring her up 24 7. i got it i got
it
come on now mm-hmm i thought it was
gonna be a hard question yeah jane's
right uh stop trying to make gazebo
happen
it's not gonna happen
all
right
i'm talking about seattle seahawks
number one fan and the number one number
maybe number two owner of my heart after
her daughter
linda oh
okay what did you play zach well i i i
originally had dale's evo
jk diane but i i think tommy's right i i
got diane but
what did you put
i put mama clemens oh
okay wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute what'd you put
butcher um i put linda because i saw the
other toy
ah yes
very butcher behavior and i'll have it
yeah i mean i didn't know but i know her
a sexy mama
[Applause]
okay so i think the score is like one to
one to one to one to two to zero
honestly the chat truly did win chad is
the winner
thank you guys for coming to just fest
thanks for the chat being my best friend
my lovers my husbands wives sisters
brothers everything you guys are truly
what make justfest just
you know
and i'm feeling you know like all good
comic-cons as they begin to wind down
okay we have to start discounting stuff
oh so i'm going to move redemptions down
a bit okay every 50
we'll hit a redemption now every 50
we're gonna hit a redemption until the
remainder of the show
uh or we run out of how about how about
this too tommy if we hit at 350 why
don't we pop open both those pop open
both boxes
just songs after three that's right okay
all right so we get to 350 two more
treasures after that we're singing our
hearts out now
you may have noticed it's not just your
average four
break room today we have special guests
and they came in special costumes
i wouldn't be a comic-con without a
cosplay contest and even though zach is
in cosplay uh as my dad's best friend
zach and i are gonna be trying to chat
saying zach's
we have decided that we are going to
uh we're going to have a little cosplay
contest but first this is crazy
i actually had a celebrity friend wish
me congratulations on comic con wow and
we're gonna we're gonna play his video
now this is really nice of him let me
see
hi it's me harrison ford
i'm sorry i can't be at comic-con this
year
what
tommycon
what the hell is tommycon
that's [ __ ]
okay oh harrison ford high as a kite
kinda
kinda hurtful but uh it's kind of mean
well i think that's been his reputation
for years but not for me my frequent
co-star and best friend harrison ford we
love you here at comic-con you're
welcome anytime please no more landing
the red baron on hole nine at the
santa monica plenty of room here in
burbank that's that plane no we're in
northbourne
pasadena without further ado we're gonna
have a cosplay contest and there's gonna
be three votes there's gonna be zach's
vote there's gonna be my vote okay and
then of course
there will be an audience vote no you're
you're you're okay cosplaying his
punchline so please line up
and then da daschle if you don't mind
we're gonna walk we're gonna have
everyone catwalk here and john do we
have any just random catwalky music i
know i didn't tell you this do you have
how about the backing track to my own
worst enemy since we're not going to
sing that
i'm sorry
that's okay i i kind of remember this
that's the
name
no no surprise to me okay all right
and listen introduce yourself and your
cosplay
uh
hello i'm i'm brandon uh i am president
loki wow
that's one president i
got
wouldn't
impeach
a post right yeah you got to pose
yeah
yeah
nice word wow would love it great
where's the music uh it's not good i'll
do it i'm too sexy for this costume too
sexy for this costume oh
hi how's it going i'm anna you would
think i'm winnie the pooh but
plot twist
i'm the one from the new horror oh
good honey
bloody
sexy for this costume too sexy for this
costume too sexy for this costume
oh
state your name i'm jessica hi hi but
i'm um cosplaying as punchline from the
dc
comics and i just want to say that if
you heard me over there i forgot my
microphone was on and don't think about
what i thought
about what i said
classic punchline
to moves too sexy for this costume
too sexy for this costume
bring out my girlfriend today i'm billy
butcher wow i'm just gonna make sure
that no suits come and mess up my mate
tommy's comic-con all right we don't
want him to bollocks it off all off or
anything like that so if anything goes
down you let me know all right
talk about scorched earth in my crotch
hey everybody i'm erica wusu cosplaying
is miles morales spiderman himself
and that's my costume
i would swing over to that spider-man's
room any time
after that it's clearly time to a redeem
some of these boxes oh
it's time for the judges to deliberate
how about how about the winner will
allow to punch through one of the boxes
that's right okay thank you in the super
chat so zach do you have your vote for
winner
wait wait can i do my bit for my costume
oh you have a [ __ ]
do you have a good joke to deliver his
punchline
why would you come at me like that
in her honor
uh how do you know i'm telling a dad
joke
how well that should be a parent
that's my man
all right your vote uh my vote you know
what they all did such a great job and i
like the uh the performance elements of
all of them uh but i gotta say
both the accuracy and the um diy quality
of of brandon's president yeah thank you
yeah i want it over for me
i want to go through and i want to thank
my aunt barb for making this winnie the
pooh costume
uh eric you look great tom you make a an
absolutely gorgeous billy butcher
joker your punchline you know that the
only punch you have to do is punch a
ticket on our wedding license oh
but adorable i have to vote for
president loki as well because it's so
awesome it's good it's so perfect so
friends
do me a favor and punch that bucket okay
oh
it's super teddy my childhood
you can't kill what's already
super teddy's revenge now we've got one
more bucket we set it 350 we'd punch it
who here wants to punch the final bucket
can i nominate someone yeah yeah butcher
because butcher wasn't in the poll yeah
butcher got home
hawaii's coming in slowly
okay butcher erasure
i blame youtube's algorithm
what is it
it's a wwe soccer thank god signed by
mick foley also i will say game used by
me
yeah
yeah
but i got some great news we are way
over our next redemption so it's time to
sing another song
who is ready to sing since we weren't
able to sing their bigots
enemy yeah we'll be singing the lesser
known lit cat bat catalog yes
let's uh let's get john out here as we
sing can you put the address the email
address at the bottom a lot of people
are asking for it
and also if someone won the morbius
thing let me know
all right and we are singing i want it
that way by the backstreet boys
baby john get out here and sing
okay here we go everybody that's
watching
get in here john
you are
my fire
the one
desiree
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
tell me why
may be coming to a close
but comic-con will never die we want to
do a little last few things some of our
super chatters here bobby shattuck
giving us a nice 50 dollar token easy 75
perry clemens no relation mike no marvin
gonzalez we also want to thank everybody
who made this show possible today
samantha corey for drawing this amazing
incredible amazing poster comic con
email and you're getting one of those
email address if you want to sign copy
that it's free baby just email us then
we own your address i'm going to come to
your house and i'm going to make you
dinner we also want to thank all of our
guests for joining us erica woo
we've got tom michaelson i want to thank
anna
she was the first lady
i heard it all right sorry i want to
thank john costa as always yes sure
on the camera hank the dog this
to
is
a lot of people want to know will there
be atomicon 2023 whoa and all i got to
say about that is
you bet your life there well yeah
so to take us out
we are honored we are privileged to have
an incredible song
sung by the artist ladies and gentlemen
singing his hit song of the summer gary
oldman it's zack huddleston and his
huddle stands
thank you phillip now
okay
when do we come in to the tune of mamma
mia
so i made up my mind it must come to an
end
and i suddenly lose control
there's a fire within my soul
just one face and no
gary oldman can you face me
my mom give up your family
wow oh wait
the discord clip of the week baby
give me camera four for a
[Music]
hang on second screamer
[Music]
we have to always go back now
that was a tamakon